hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled the formation of an
international collaborative network to
find
covid19 therapeutics this webinar is
part of the coronavirus virtual event
series
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i
will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left
of your screen as a reminder this
presentation
is educational and offers continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top
right corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
without further ado i now present
today's speakers
first up will be nevin krogen dr krogan
is a professor of cellular and molecular
pharmacology at ucsf
principal investigator at gladstone
institute of data
science and biotechnology and the
director of the quantitative bios
science institute and then following
nevin will be jacqueline fabius and she
is the chief
operating officer at the quantitative
bioscience institute
welcome to both of you nevin you may
begin your presentation
welcome sir
all right thank you susie and um i'd
like to
thank lab roots for giving us this uh
opportunity to present
uh on our work uh with uh sars kobe 2
and uh kovid 19.
we're going to be discussing
the background and
the work that's been done at the
quantitative biosciences institute over
the last
several years and show you how we why we
were so well prepared to respond
to this particular pandemic and
jacqueline is going to focus
on that aspect during her part of the
presentation and i'm going to focus
more on some of the science that's been
on the context
of the qcrg the qbi corner virus
research group so just to give you a bit
of scientific background of the
quantitative biosciences institute and a
lot of the research that
i am personally involved in what we
really try to do is to develop
and use in an integrative way a number
of different
ideologies and focus them in a
disease-agnostic way
on a variety of different disease areas
an attempt to get at the underlying
biology behind these disease areas
in an attempt also to identify novel
therapeutic strategies so
as you can see in the venn diagram there
in blue we're heavily involved in
studying protein protein interactions
and post translational modifications
using
mass spectrometry we try to merge that
information together with more
functional data
a genetics data in a pink and we're
doing a lot of crispr based
uh genetics and genetic interaction
analysis which i'll be talking about
we're also not heavily involved in a
structural list
of proteins and protein complexes both
uh computational and experimental
with a large focus now on uh cryogenium
as you're going to hear about
and then we also try to merge together
different chemo informatics and chemical
biology
approaches as well so we're trying to
put all these different tools together
in an
integrative way i mean you can think
about it as in a pipeline
or almost like a gun and you can point
the gun
at pretty much anything any organism
any uh disease area and uh we've
focused on several disease areas
by focusing this pipeline on them in the
formation of these different
initiatives uh so one big focus is on
cancer
um they're at the the top on the right
to the cancer cell map initiative
we're also um appointing this suite of
integrative technologies
on neuropsychiatric and
neurodegenerative diseases in the
context of the psychiatric
cell map initiative and then we're
heavily involved
in using these tools to study in an
unbiased way the host pathogen interface
in in under the umbrella of the host
pathogen
mapping initiative and it's under this
initiative where we've carried out a lot
of work
studying sars kobe 2. and as i said
we're heavily involved in mass
spectrometry based approaches
one big thing we do is um create
protein protein interaction maps and
here are a number of host pathogen
protein protein interaction maps that
we've generated over the last
uh a decade uh we've been focusing on a
variety of different pathogens including
hiv influenza ebola dengue zika
and bacterial species such as media and
i just wanted to show this
up front uh because normally
it takes at least a year to generate one
of these maps and oftentimes
longer but we generated a sars kobe 2
human protein protein interaction map
in the matter of a couple weeks and to
me that's a testament to the
collaborative spirit
that went in to
the creation of the qc rg
which is connected to the quantitative
biosciences institute and now jacqueline
is going to give you a little bit of
background
about the institute and what we've been
doing over the last several years
a little bit about qbi and its
philosophy and why we were perfectly
situated for the formation
of a group like the qcrg the qbi
coronavirus research group
so qbi has 103 labs affiliated to it
for collaborative research which is
quantitative it's discovery science
disease agnostic experimental and
computational
as nevin just went into we are we're
known for our cell mapping initiatives
the ccmi
hpmi and pcmi nevin will be
going into great depth into hpmi as we
discuss the covid19 story
and we are well known for our focus
on young scientists as well as the
empowerment of
women across the board at qbi however i
would say that we are
mostly known for our varied uh
and ample events that are joint symposia
seminars and other things other events
and activities where we
try to really just think out of the box
and what we've done is try to bring
science
to the community not only our own
scientific community but the lay
audience
and the broader community outside and so
for example we've
sometimes combined art exhibits around
our symposia to broaden the mind
we had arthropod-borne disease symposium
last year and we coupled this with
a lyme disease panel with a number of
experts nih
uh industry academia and
we also teamed up with usaid who had
done a specific
uh photo project around zika and people
living with zika in central america
and so we had an extensive photo exhibit
with stories of people
living with zika babies and so on uh
in tandem with the uh symposium
similarly with
a psychiatric cell map initiative
symposium we also
had an art exhibit focusing on the brain
and had a number of pieces created by
people living with autism
also interestingly we created salons
around specific research topics we did
this
with a company called living mactavish
and these salons are essentially
fireside chats
with experts and so we had them
around various topics around psychiatry
and
neurological uh disorders cancer
infectious diseases and crispr and so on
and these
these are a completely different kind of
atmosphere where people come
in a very intimate setting to interact
with the scientists who are at the top
of their
field to be able to ask all kinds of
questions and
these salons gathered influencers as
well as
affluent people who typically have a lot
of impact within their own communities
we focused at qbi also at really
uh bringing out the scientists as real
people in our social media campaigns
and we interviewed them to ask you know
what inspire what inspires a scientist
where do you start you know how do you
see your life how do you want to be
remembered
and these interviews were put out on
instagram on a regular basis featuring
different scientists
from all across qbi so 103 uh
we've come close to interviewing 70 now
and
we're moving forward with that as well
other fun things that we did
uh were things like cooking with a
scientist and
this was also teamed up with living
mctavish where
the scientist who has an expertise in
something say crispr
is learning how to cook with uh with a
living mctavish but also
talking and being interviewed about
their science at the same time
over the meal they're preparing and
eventually eating and so this was a
quite dynamic sort of uh
interaction where people could ask live
questions
as we went along we have a qbi
fellowship and currently our fellow is
clement verba who will play a role
in the story that nevin's going to be
telling you about the qcrg
the qbi fellowship identifies promising
standout candidates to speed up their
career from graduate student to
independent pi it's a two-year
fellowship
where they are granted office space a
small amount of lab space
and funding to essentially prosper
um and so klim you'll be hearing a lot
more about his science further down
um our presentation but interestingly in
addition to working with cryuem
and so on klim also led a number of uh
very successful hackathons around
scientific imaging
with mass spectrometry and cryo-em which
combined
industry designers and scientists
together in
48 hour marathons essentially and
interestingly after the first hackathon
there was a paper published it came out
of this essentially 48 hour effort
we also have a scholarship for women
from developing nations and biosciences
this of course is obviously an
opportunity for capacity building for
someone who comes from a developing
nation
however on our side and their site it's
also a great opportunity for
international collaborations and
partners to develop because typically
these women go back
to their science institutes or
universities in the countries they come
from
and they become the leaders of the
collaborations happening with ucsf
and other institutes and academic
places that they would have made contact
with during their year at qbi so going
going further into collaboration and how
we
really foster this atmosphere we created
the qbi happy hours and these were
hosted at a local bar that had screens
and
each month three labs would hand pick um
post docs who would have five minutes to
present
up to up to three slides so essentially
flash talks followed by five minutes of
questions
and i think as you can see in the
picture this was a very relaxed
atmosphere that led to a lot of
mingling and discussion and in fact did
lead
to a lot of collaborations really
starting at the ground level with the
post docs and graduate students
and we were enthusiastically told once
that it was like match.com for
scientists
we therefore thought it was a great
success so continuing with the vision of
collaboration that we have
it really comes back to the uh cell
mapping initiatives that nevin mentioned
earlier
and each of these is actually comprised
of 10 pis 10 to 15 pis in their labs
so you can see that each of these
represents either close to or well over
100 scientists working on a specific
problem whether that's cancer
psychiatric or neurodegenerative
disorders or
infectious diseases so as such
uh we go back to remind you the cell
maps that
uh that are created through protein
protein interactions
and we started thinking well what if
what if in the same way we map the cells
we start mapping the world with
collaborative interactions
what if cell mapping equal world mapping
and protein-protein interactions in fact
equal
people-people interactions so with this
we started looking at the world and
where we were
interacting and mapping our activity
just as we do in the cell but mapping
the globe
uh looking at where we were interacting
with institutions
uh industry scientists and
essentially everything that has to do
with the scientific world and we quickly
realized that scientists in fact
fell into very specific networks that
were focused on
different topics whether that's
technology cancer cardiovascular
and so on and importantly you'll notice
that in our infectious disease network
you'll see that new york
and paris were identified in our network
well before our current crisis uh nevin
will be speaking more about those
relationships
in his his section of the presentation
at this time at qbi we have a number of
formal international collaborations
with germany ireland france nigeria
poland
israel the uk to name a few and
importantly i'm highlighting the
institut pasteur because they play an
important role in the story of
the qcrg and the formation of the qcrg
the qbi coronavirus research group
was really the understanding of the
context of a coming pandemic
and taking action it was a rising
opportunity to change how science can be
done
through extensive collaboration and lead
to radical advancements
42 labs at ucsf came together to
research covet 19
each bringing their own expertise to
address the problem and nevin's going to
go deeper into that story now
best with a diverse set of skills
from systems biologists structural
biologists computer scientists
virologists
and we all came together in a very
unique collaborative and unprecedented
way i would argue
to try to bring our tools together um
to try to come up with solutions for
this particular pandemic so
ultimately we if you look at all the
labs there's hundreds of different
scientists
associated with the qcrg based out of
um qbi and it got so big we had to split
them into
a dozen subgroups and these subgroups
are focused on different aspects of
studying covet 19 from
more technological aspects like looking
at structural biology with
led by clem burban or rosenberg or drug
discovery led by kevin shortcut and
brian schreiket
and then we have subgroups focused on
different
biological processes that the virus is
on
gene on for example david rajara leads
the translational subgroup
and denisa fujimori and alan ashworth
lead the epigenetics
and chromatin a subgroup so we have
essentially hundreds of different
scientists being connected through these
uh
different subgroups and working together
i would argue in a way that hasn't been
done if it's not
at ucsf and at qbi
so one of the focuses here of the qcrg
is to try to
in a systematic way understand how the
virus comes in
and hijacks and rewires the host during
the course of
infection and then use this information
to try to develop
uh therapies there's a lot of effort
going on around the world including that
qcrg trying to find
drugs or compounds that would target
specific viral proteins
and that's great but we're also trying
to understand
which human genes and proteins the virus
needs to infect ourselves and then
try to use that information to come up
with novel
therapies and host directed therapies
and there's advantages
for looking at host directed therapies
for example you don't have to worry so
much about resistance because
obviously we don't mutate as fast as uh
the virus we and others have shown that
different viruses seemingly very
different viruses in some cases
hijack similar post machinery similar
pathways
and complexes and proteins so the idea
is if you have a therapeutic strategy
against one virus it could be applicable
for other viruses
some that may not even be that related
and of course there's disadvantages for
targeting human proteins
and toxicity is is a big issue but this
is why we're
initially at fda approved drugs or
compounds and clinical trials that have
passed toxicity issues so hopefully
that wouldn't be such a big problem as
we try to repurpose these drugs
to try to fight coping 19. so in the
bottom left there
there's about 30 genes associated with
car cobia 2 and that's compared to 20
000 genes and proteins in each one of
our
cells so the virus obviously can't live
by itself it needs our cells and our
genes and our proteins in order to
live and replicate and infect us so the
challenge here is to
try to define which human genes and
proteins
do the does the virus need to infect us
and we carried out a protein protein
interaction analysis where i'll go into
detail in just a minute to identify
332 genes or proteins we generated a map
and then
we looked at those genes and proteins
and then identified
drugs or compounds that we thought would
target at least one of those proteins
and then we wanted to see if any of
those happy viral effects and this was
a work that was published a couple of
months ago
that's the sars kobe 2 protein
interaction map reveals targets for drug
repurposing
you can see there's a lot of authors on
this paper i think over 130 authors
involving
30 different laboratories around the
world and
this is why we could move so fast
because of the collaborative
collaborative spirit that went into
this particular work and just to give
you a little bit of a background
on this particular project so back in
january david gordon a talented postdoc
in the lab
heard about this virus and he started to
slice these genes one at a time
i think we were the first group to
actually synthesize all of them
all 16 non-structural proteins four
structural proteins and then
the putative accessory factors and we
put affinity tags on them a strep tag a
2x strep tag
and then we expressed them in heck 293
cells and then purified each one of them
wanted it totally and then characterized
the co-purifying
human proteins by mass spectrometry
and then we used algorithms to come up
with what we said as a high confidence
quantitative stars called v2
human protein protein interaction map
and as i said i think we were the first
group
to clone out or synthesize each one
of these and at the time we released the
initial map it was on by our archive in
march we just tweeted out
in the lab twitter account that we had
these clones and we would be happy to
send them
to whoever wants them no strings
attached no mtas
please feel free to distribute and we'll
even pay for shipping and
in a couple of weeks we actually sent
these scenes
to almost 400 labs in 40
different countries and i'd like to
comment that
that these plasmids these genes went
around the world a lot faster than the
virus
itself so we're very happy that we were
able to send out these reagents
to the research community in an effort
to expedite
uh understanding this virus so we can
come up with
hopefully therapeutic strategies so this
was the initial map that we had um
reported so 332 sars kobe 2 human
protein protein interactions
including 66 different proteins that we
classify it as drugable corresponding to
69 different
drugs and compounds and in this
representation
the red diamonds correspond to the sars
cov2 protein
the other nodes correspond to human
proteins
uh if those nodes are orange we think
that it's a potential uh druggable
target
and on the right hand side there we
actually partnered with
a company called zoic labs it's a
company based out of hollywood it's
involved
in making movies it was involved in
making titanic and
a life of pie biz stone the founder of
twitter and ron conaway got us connected
with this
company and we've actually worked with
them uh to take our data and put it into
a very impressive website
so it's a very cool way to peruse this
information
and if you're interested in our data and
in this map i'd encourage you
to look at this particular website we're
putting other information
into this framework not just our data
but other people's data so we think it's
a fantastic tool that many
people have been left to try to get
hypotheses
of how sars cov2 works based on this and
related type of information
so our goal now is to take this map and
then identify
human proteins that have drugs or
compounds that would bind to and inhibit
them and then we could test if they have
any
effects so in total uh the work led by
brian shoyket and kayvon show cap they
identified 69 different
drugs and compounds it's a mixture of
fda approved drugs drugs and clinical
trials
and pre-clinical compounds on the left
there i'm just saying room disappears is
one compound obviously that has an
effect
that targets a viral protein the
question is are any of these other ones
would they be fruitful in terms of
having antiviral effects
against asar's uh kogi ii
um so i'm going to come back to our work
trying to test these drugs
but then i'm going to hand it back off
to jacqueline she's going to tell you
about some of the stuff that have been
going on in the background as we've been
generating these maps and making these
predictions
so as the work was advancing extremely
quickly with the scientists we found it
very important
to keep people informed and often
informed
because as we've all experienced has
been an avalanche of information about
covid19 which is not necessarily clear
to everyone sometimes a bit
too scientific in in the jargon for the
average person to understand
and we found it very important to keep
the public donors
staff government agencies darpa
et cetera biotech pharma and media
itself informed as to what was actually
going on with the research
with the qcrg we have a really
sensational media team which was on task
immediately not only interviewing uh
various scientists and creating videos
uh but also just putting out information
on twitter on a regular basis as well as
instagram and so on
and we found that the first paper was
put onto by our archive and
we experienced a sudden media explosion
there was there was news all over the
place about the the findings the paper
the authors
and as many of you who are in the
audience i suspect are scientists
you know that it's fantastic to get uh
media attention but it's not always
exactly what you think is the focus or
what you have found to be important in
your research that's highlighted in the
story
and so we took it upon ourselves to
write our own story
and make sure that the the message we
felt was very correct
was getting out there to people in a
very understandable voice
a real voice that speaks to lay
audiences the way you would speak to
your family or your grandmother for
example
to explain something and so we set about
writing blogs
creating op-ed pieces and making sure
that ucsf also had our voice out there
with personal accounts of what was going
on with the research
the stuff is complicated as you know and
so we really tried to dilute it down to
its essence for people to understand
what was going on and what the research
was we already had qbi tv but with the
advent of covet 19 we ramped up our
efforts to have a number of series
uh and and programs focused on uh the
coronavirus and what it meant across the
board
we were quite uh lucky in having an
intern this year
leila shokat who is a major in
anthropology and who is very curious
about some of the questions around covet
19 and its effect
on the scientific community and so she
led a number of programs around this
topic
in addition we also had some very
specific and special programs like
the uh french console of san francisco
who interviewed nevin krogan as director
of qbi
and christophe danfer as director of the
pasteur institute
about the ongoing collaboration between
the two but also
the importance and its focus uh that
happened during covid19
other programs focused on what covet 19
means to
the young scientists and how it's
potentially changing their research
as well as how has coveted 19 affected
women in science
as heads of families and what that means
we also try to be innovative again and
to see how do we share the information
that's coming out of the qcrg which is
quite complex
uh science and biology and so we thought
about
the the 16 60 minutes show that many of
you are familiar with i'm sure and we
did a sort of
spin-off as you wish called 60 seconds a
qcrg minute
and the qcrg minute focuses on young
scientists and trainees and tells their
story
focusing on their bit of what they are
working on so again these are
one of the roughly 400 scientists who
are working through the subgroups that
nevin mentioned
and we focus on their science so coming
up next a quick one minute video to show
you what one of these is like
go ahead tyler
is this virus able to actually get
inside of the heart
and affect the cell types within the
heart directly we found that
cardiomyocytes
which are the main cell type in the
heart that drives contraction
and gives it most of the function and
ability to pump blood
to our surprise were very susceptible
they harbored
very large amounts of virus after being
infected with a very low
initial amount of virus so it was clear
that they were also
probably not only being infected but
replicating
and creating even more virus and
spreading that affection pretty quickly
within our within our cultures so since
then we've been doing a lot of work to
compare what we're finding and what
we're discovering in in vitro in these
cell-based systems and
potential ways to actually block that
from occurring and the different
mechanisms of viral entry
and we're also looking in patient
samples
to understand if there's a correlation
if there if we're actually capturing
what might be happening in the live
human heart
muscular subgroup similarly as
advertised uh today and tomorrow on the
lab routes website we have another show
coming up tomorrow that i
strongly encourage you to watch hiv 2020
where are we at now the intersection of
hiv and community service because while
we are focused on covet 19 obviously
other diseases are still ongoing as is
the research for them
and so tune in tomorrow you can find
this easily on our website qbi.ucsf.edu
click on the news tab and you'll be able
to log
in so what we found as a result
of this avalanche of
information and communication that we've
put out is an army of willingness that
has come out of this nevin mentioned
this stone the co-founder of twitter but
we found that numerous people came out
of the woodwork
just essentially celebrating the
research and supporting it very vocally
and this uh translated into different
ways of support but also
interestingly the introduction to
various companies such as zoic labs
which nevin mentioned with a very
interesting interactive map that they
created
but as well benchling for example a
digital uh
lab notebook company which has offered
their lab notebooks for free
for a year uh at for the structural
biology consortium
and synthego a great company that we've
been partnering with and collaborating
with who's been doing crispr knockouts
for the qcrg and now back to nevin with
the drug discovery
so we as i said before we had
generated this map and made these
predictions about these 69 different
drugs and compounds that we thought
could have
antiviral effects and we needed to test
them and unfortunately we did not have
the virus propagating
using or in the bay area in general
recent work by
the gladstone working but at the time in
march we did not have it so
what we did was leverage our our
work uh in order to test
our drug predictions and in particular
uh we collaborated with
um with marco vignuzzi olivia schwartz
christophe don faire
and veronica as well as
at mount sinai hospital at the
department of microbiology
in new york with a good friend and
collaborator that we've worked with many
years on
adolfo garcia sastra and in
collaboration
with the suite in
his group so we reached out to our
collaborators
and we sent them the drugs and the
compounds so they could test to see if
they have any antiviral effects
so an interesting backstory with this is
that
uh obviously as we were sending drugs to
new york and paris sending them to new
york was not an issue
but sending them to paris in uh
march april may was proving to be
extremely uh complicated with the travel
bans and all kinds of other things
happening with
mail services and things around the
world and the french council called us
and asked if there was anything that
they could do to help
we've had a long-standing relationship
with them dating back
to our first annual joint symposium with
the
pasteur institute where they were
involved and so in fact there was
something that they could do into the
console in the purple shirt
on the left called the french ambassador
in dc
who himself called the head of fedex in
the united states as well as the head of
french customs
to make sure that our drugs and
compounds were
shipping safely and making it easily end
on time to the institute pastor for the
assays that nevin is going to be telling
you about
uh in two different continents that we
employ to test
our drugs and compounds we initially
used vero six cells
african green monkey cells at the time
there were no
cells that were available for these type
of assays of course there are now which
i'll get to
in a few minutes by the time we used
zero six cells we were adding drugs or
compounds
two for infection uh two different mois
it was four times higher in paris versus
new york and we let the assay go for
uh two days and then fixed with
formaldehyde and in new york
on the top right there we were using an
antibody against np as our readout
it was a microscopy based readout and
doing tcid50
phases where we could and in paris
instead of looking at the
protein component of the virus we're
looking at the rna component using qrt
pcr
and then carrying out plaque assays as
well so we're doing
two different assays in two different
content
continents and i think that gave us
confidence um when we saw
positive results so and you're able to
uh screen about two-thirds
of the drugs and compounds that we had
initially uh predicted and this
allowed us to narrow in on a couple of
sets of drugs that we were excited about
the first set um are those connected to
protein translation or protein
biogenesis the
particular uh process the first one here
is
a zotarofin uh zotafin is from the
company
effector and that was co-founded by a
couple of ucsf faculty including davide
ruggiero
and i'm kayvon shokadin zotarofin is
known to
bind to a translational initiation
protein called ef4a
and eif4a is regulated by a helicase
called eif4h and we found eif4h in
our protein protein interaction map
binding to
nsp9 so that led us to that particular
compound that's actually in a clinical
trial right now for multiple
myeloma now in phase two and then the
other is another translation inhibitor
connecting four this was synthesized by
jack taunton at
ucsf it's known to bind to and inhibit a
translational
uh elongation protein called eif a1a
interestingly there is a drug that's
approved in europe to treat again
multiple myeloma that targets eif-1a as
well
called platepepsin or aptidine and
actually applauding podepsin is in the
clinical trial right now
for covet-19 and they're getting
actually quite
positive results and we're actually
working now with effector with sotadifen
to get this into a clinical trial as
well
for uh covet so translation inhibitors
are one
class that we're excited about another
are sigma r1 r2
modulators these are receptors that came
out of our protein protein interaction
map we're most excited about sigma r1
in that we found it binding to nsp6
in sars kobe 2 and there's a number of
putative sigma
on mars that uh we found to have
antiviral effects including
different antihistamines antipsychotics
like haloperidol
anti-malarial drug this is our friend
hydroxychloroquine the female hormone
progesterone
and then some preclinical compounds uh
such
as pb28
and just to go a little bit more detail
into the assays uh with zotafin
and trinaten4 in pledetsen we found
antiviral effects both
in new york and paris there is some
toxicity here
that were that we thought was toxicity
it's actually not toxicity that's
cytostatic um uh
trends that were seen here with the
black line compared
very beautiful data now in primary cells
showing that the tadafan has very
potent antiviral effects and we're doing
work with adolfo cs astra
with these drugs in mice and hamsters as
well and getting very great data there
and then here's just some data antiviral
data that we see
with the antihistamines the
anti-malarial drugs and
the pre-compound and we're quite excited
actually about pb28 this was a molecule
that was originally synthesized in the
90s
to target sigma r1 it was originally
being used
to be developed as an antipsychotic drug
so we're quite excited about um pb28
and what we showed here in the original
paper that actually pb28 is
much more killing the virus then
hydroxychloroquine we actually find
it's 20 times more potent uh this is
data on the right from chris white in
adolfa garcia sesters lab in new york
where he's generated uh these um
antiviral plots
and you can see the ic 90s here it's 20
times more potent pb28 is
than hydroxyl ventilated with
uh the fact that pb28 has 20 times
greater affinity for binding to sigma r1
compared to hydroxychloroquine and this
was data generated
for us by brian roth an expert on these
receptors
from the university of north carolina so
of course hydroxycorkin has been in the
news
um as potentially having positive
effects or not having positive effects
but i think what people can agree on
there is toxicity
associated with hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine
and there's cardiotoxicity in particular
so we looked at this in more detail with
brian roth
and on the right there he actually finds
that hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
tightly to the herb receptor that's the
receptor on the heart
it binds much more tightly to the herd
receptor than it binds to
sigma r1 receptors especially when you
compare it
a binding of other sigmar one modulators
such as pb28
and clemenstein so if you look at the
sigma r1 binding patterns
in purple there is 28 you can see it's
binding quite tightly in orange is
clemostine and antihistamine
so it's binding much more tightly to
sigma r1 than to herb
so these drugs these other sigma r1
modulators they may have
other toxic effects but we don't think
that have cardiotoxic effects at least
not to the same degree
as hydroxychloroquine and at the time we
did this we could not do genetic
experiments
to confirm that sigma r1 or sigma r2
is a crucial for infection so but we
generated this venn diagram looking at
all the compounds and looking at what
was known
to be targeted by those compounds and
all the different you know the pb28 the
antipsychotics the antihistamines and so
forth
that we're known to target be targeted
by all of them whereas sigma r1 and
sigma r2 so we do think these are key
proteins
satisfyingly in data that we haven't
published yet which i'll get to in a few
minutes
when you genetically perturb sigma r1
you have a big impact
on uh quarter virus infection confirming
the pharmacological predictions that we
made in the nature paper i'd like to
transition now to
the the second paper that the qcrg had
published
and this is the global phosphorylation
landscape of stars kobe 2 infection it's
got a lot of the same characters
from the initial paper and
this is where we try to id to unbiased
way
all the kinases that are being hijacked
and rewired by the virus
during the course of infection i think
this is important for a couple reasons
um there's approximately 500 kinases in
our cells
and i like to think of kinases of the of
the master switchboard of the cell
so the virus can manipulate this set of
proteins
it's a very way to manipulate the entire
cell
so understanding that would be very
advantageous and another important point
here there's a lot of drugs and
compounds that target kinases so if you
could find the kinases the virus needs
you could then jump over to the drugs
and compounds to see if they
have any ultimate antiviral effects
so what we did here again it's a host
directed type of analysis
is that we looked in infected cells and
we globally assess changes of
phosphorylation in a time dependent
manner
t 0 all the way down to t24 here 24
hours
and we saw which phosphorylation sites
were either up regulated
or down regulated both those proteins
and actually on the viral proteins
as well and we could start to cluster
this data and find
different groups of proteins based on
their phosphorylation dynamics you can
see in the cluster one
these are proteins that are becoming
more and more phosphorylated as
transfection or as
infection goes on and then you have
certain cases like clusters
or where you have hypophosphorylation as
uh infection progresses so based on this
information we could collaborate with
the scientist pedro beltrayo at ebi embl
who was one of the world's experts at
looking at phosphorylation changes
and then identifying the kinases that
are being most misregulated and this is
exactly what he did
to identify kinases that are seemingly
turned up in red
or turned down in blue
so then we can narrow in from 500
colonases down to maybe about 50 kinases
that we think the virus needs
and then we could talk to kaevan showcat
at ucsf who's one of the
world's experts on pharmacologically
inhibiting kinases a
good walk and he's got this big freezer
of essentially
all kinase inhibitors for all kinases
and we told him the kinases that we
thought were being misregulated
and then he gave us a list of kinase
inhibitors that we looked in
more detail just to go through some of
these which we're excited about one here
is
case in kinase ii you can see there on
the left
that the two most unregulated uh kinases
there are
actually two sub subunits of casein
kinase two uh so there's a drug there
um that's actually in the clinical trial
for cancer
um four cases in counties two and we
actually found that it has antiviral
effects
um in assays both in paris and new york
interestingly we actually found
cases physically associated with the n
protein and our protein protein
interaction map so there's two
connections
to casein kinase ii so we've been very
interested in
in that enzyme and i'm going to come
back to that in just a minute
we also found that certain cdks were
being misregulated and cdk inhibitors
also had antiviral effects the pfi
kinase
as well and then we also found multiple
components of the p38
map kinase cascade were being
manipulated by the virus as well
and this is important because there's
many kinases in this cascade and there's
a lot of drugs a lot of anti-cancer
drugs
that have been developed to target
kinases in this pathway and we found a
couple here down
the bottom left that did have antiviral
effects and on the bottom right what i'm
showing you here is
we used rnai to knock down uh several of
these map counties
and found anti-viral effects so the
genetics supported the pharmacology
that we had uncovered the predictions
ultimately from our global
phosphorylation study so we got a number
of kinase inhibitors that we've been
very excited about i just want to go
back to the case in kinase 2
connection we wanted to look at this in
more
detail and we started to collaborate
with robert gross at the university of
freiburg
in germany we wanted to see if we could
co-localize
the end protein with case and kinase do
we find a physical
connection between affected cells do we
see an overlap there
so he carried out microscopy experiments
for us and he was quite excited
he he called me up and he was very
excited when he started to look at
infected cells he said
well look you see this these string be
like filipodia
that the virus is inducing in an
infection-dependent
um manner now these are kind of actin
related
or actin um contained um
protrusions and other viruses make this
such as vaccinia and
influenza but not to this extent and the
idea here is that they poke holes
um and uh it's like a channel where one
virus can go from one
cell to an h2 independent manner and
what he saw here although other viruses
caused filippodi he saw this branching
here
which had never been seen before so this
could be a reason why the virus is so
infectious it's a another mechanism
how the virus can go from um cell to
cell well then he looked to see where
the end protein and casein kinase ii
were localized and sure enough they were
co
local themselves uh in the filipodia so
our model here is that case in kinase 2
is helping with this filiponia formation
so we also collaborated with elizabeth
fisher at rocky mountain labs in montana
and she generated
some beautiful images for us using
electron microscopy
there is one slice there you can see the
fillipodia and at the
tip you can see the viral particles
budding off of the filopodium
there's another picture that elizabeth
generated for us the
red spaghetti is the the filopodia and
then obviously the
yellow balls or the viruses butting off
of the filipodia
and our model right now here is that um
there's pathways delayed by a couple of
different proteins
that are resulting in this filopodia
formation we think that the end protein
there on the right
is hijacking case in counties 2 in a way
that's resulting in certain
phosphorylate
phosphorylation events that allow for
this philopodial formation we also think
the role pathway is being manipulated by
nsp7 in a way that's
down regulating phosphorylation on a set
of proteins and for whatever reason
that's now beneficial
for filipino formation so we're looking
at this in greater detail and i just
want to show you one more picture here
it's again from elizabeth fisher
it's a very beautiful and creepy picture
these are like tentacle like
structures that are coming off infected
cells and the the blue
balls here in this case are the viral
particles buddy
and i really like this image because
it's both beautiful
but also biologically interesting as
well and those are the best type of
pictures i would argue
so there was a few write-ups of us
jacqueline alluded to some of the press
that we had
earlier at the end of june the san
francisco chronicle highlighted some of
our
drugs at the time there were actually
three clinical trials that had started
based on this work
uh since then there's actually been
three more that have been started
and we're actually quite excited here at
the top with so tadafan as i told you
before
uh with effector we're working with them
now to get this particular drug
into a clinical trial so some
i'm going now we're trying to transition
into clinical trials as i've alluded to
with some of our findings
we're very interested in combinatorial
studies because i think that's
i think that's what's going to be needed
here is a cocktail just like we have for
hiv and the question is what is the
combination
so we're doing a lot of combinatorial
work both pharmacology
and genetics as well or combine a lot of
our pilot from disappear because that
could be
the right strategy we're also doing a
lot of genetic work using crispr and
rnai
and generating protein protein
interaction maps using other corner
viruses such as sars kobe 1
mers and oc-43 and i just have a couple
of slides here
at the end describing some of
this work it's unpublished data it'll be
online very soon we're trying to build
pan corner virus host protein protein
interaction networks
looking at other corner viruses the a
there at the top is just basically a
rough schematic of carnovirus
genome architecture where you have the
non-structured proteins the 16 the
structural proteins the four and then
the accessory proteins
and what we did was generate protein
protein interaction maps not just on
stars kobe 2 which i talked about but
also stars kobe 1
c there and in d mers as well and we
subjected all of these
uh clones all these genes to the same
pipeline that we that i described for
stars cov2
to generate it's ours kobe 1 maps and
mers
human interaction maps uh we've also
done localization
uh experiments looking at all of these
corner bottle proteins i won't discuss
that here uh today but i do want to
discuss a little bit about the protein
protein interaction analysis that went
on
so here is the sars kobe 1 map that was
a generated and now we have a mers map
as well
and there's a number of different ways
to compare these protein protein
interaction maps and
just one simple way is to cluster the
interactions
and on the right there i've clustered
the interactions from these three
different viruses and we've
broken them down here into seven
different clusters
and the three biggest clusters here
cluster two questions that we see with
all three viruses
cluster four is just sars one and stars
two and
cluster five is just uh mers
so on the next slide here we did
something called differential
interaction mapping or scoring
to show you these interactions all three
of these different groups of clusters
on one particular map so i'm showing you
here at the bottom
left here we're just focused on these
three different clusters that i outlined
in the previous slide
and if the edges are black it means that
we see the interactions in all three
viruses
if they're blue they're more merc
specific and if they're red
they're more sars one sars2 specific so
if you just look at the top left here we
have nsp1
interestingly you have these connections
in red here with dna polymerase so we
see this is a connection with sars1 and
stars ii
but what's what's merge specific is the
connection between nsp1 and stat3
and mtor and we're following up on these
particular connections and then if you
look at the top right
we find that the end protein in sars1
stars 2
and mers physically associates with
casein kinase 2. so the prediction would
be that the casein kinase 2 inhibitor
would have antiviral effects not just on
sars2 but on these other viruses as well
so there's a wealth of information in
here
that we're very excited about that you
could be extracting a lot of hypotheses
about corner virus
research and i uh briefly alluded to the
fact
genetic analyses on our interaction map
so i want to briefly just tell you about
some of those efforts so what we did was
to take all 332 interacting proteins
that was described earlier and we did
two things we used rnai
in a549 cells expressing ace ii
we knocked down all those genes one at a
time to see what effects they have on
each and that was done collaboratively
with marco vignuzzi at the pasteur
institute
and then in b here we collaborated with
synthago jaclyn told you about that
relationship
where they knocked out each one of these
genes one at a time using crispr and
cockroach ii cells and we collaborated
with chris basler in georgia and he
looked at
what affects those ultimately infection
and we got a number of genes that had an
effect both positively
and negatively uh here's a scatter plot
comparing the two
the the balls here are the nodes in red
are genes that when knocked down by rnai
have an effect on infection in a549
cells
in yellow when they're crispered out in
coco two cells they have an effect
and in orange these are genes that have
an effect
in both cell types in using um
the different genetic perturbation
strategies in the two different
countries so there's some overlap
but there's some differences as well
here's a summary of all the genes that
we found
that have functional consequences in
either cell type using either genetic
perturbation strategy
uh and um what we wanted to do now
is now we've narrowed in on some of
these that are functionally relevant we
wanted to go then
and prioritize them and look at them
using
biochemistry biophysics and structural
biology
and this is where now we can segue back
to the qcrg
structural biology subgroup which has
really turned into a consortium this is
being led by oren rosenberg
and plym verba we have 60 different
trainees that have
come together here in this particular
consortium from 18 different
ucsf labs and of course like we're all
doing right now
this is a classic example of how zoom
has been so
in terms of expediting uh uh the the
research
and this group got so big we had to
actually split it into a number of
different
subgroups looking at mammalian protein
expression doing systematic expression
to manila cells in bacterial cells
we have a subgroup on protein
purification a subgroup on x-ray
crystallography a subgroup on
also a group focused on data processing
as well so one of the goals here
is to systematically go through each one
of these interacting factors and
characterize them
biochemically and structurally using the
genetic data
as a way to help ultimately prioritize
so now if we go back to the set of genes
that we found when perturbed have an
effect on
infection i just want to highlight one
here and uh this is the connection here
um between orf 9b and tom70
and i just want to point out that this
is a connection that is conserved
between sars kobe 2
and sarsko v1 tom70 is a mitochondrial
protein
that's involved in shuttling protein in
mitochondria
uh and uh consistent with that we
actually see orph9 be localized to the
mitochondria
and co-localizing with uh tom
70 and the qcrg structural biology
consortium actually now got just
recently got a cryo-em structure
of orph 9b binding to tom 70 and we
have a really cool video we want to show
you now so hit it tyler
so i hope you enjoy that so here is a
static picture of
tom 70 and it's binding to about
um 40 percent we got a structure of 40
percent of orphanage binding to tom 70
it's actually in the active site of tom
70.
um this was a tom 70 structure that was
elucidated
by dave agard actually several years ago
through another project and now it's
dovetailed in here with our sars kobe uh
two work and a couple of interesting
tidbits about this particular structure
that the interaction is mostly
hydrophobic with 36 of the 38 or 9b
residues that we've been able to
structurally characterize we find
interacting with tom 70.
and interestingly we can go back to our
phosphorylation dataset
find residues on orf 9b s50 and s53 that
actually phosphorylate phosphorylated
and we actually think that this
phosphorylation would be disrupting the
interaction between
tom 70 and um or 9b
and this is something that we're testing
right now and we've also given the
structure
to people like brian shoycat and under
they make more intelligent targeted
drug predictions um based on the
structure that then we're testing to see
if they have any antiviral
effects so this is just one example of
many structures that are going to be
coming out of this
uh a subgroup and this is some of the
early fruits of this particular
consortium
on the left there there are actually two
papers on bioarchive that i won't go
into
but just to briefly allude to one's a
collaboration with the sheesh
menglick and peter walter where they've
developed antibodies
nanobodies that have antiviral effects
that are targeting
uh ace ii and spike and in a similar
collaboration with jim wells
as well in the middle there there's a
couple of more publications that are
going to go online very quickly and then
on the right
uh money through darpa igi and and fast
grants
um as well so this is just a great
example of a small group within the
larger qcrg
that's having um that's made amazing
progress
over the last couple of months and along
those lines just to highlight the fact
that
we're not just collaborating in the bay
area and at ucsf and iq we have
collaborations really um around the
world i've
alluded to some of these jaclyn i have
talked about some of these with new york
and
in pasteur but there's many other groups
here
in europe and in the united states and
not just
academic relationships but industry
connections as well jacqueline told you
about several of these
including a connection with a synthago i
talked to you about
zoic labs and we also have a
relationships with big pharmaceutical
companies
uh such um as uh roche as well so it's
been a really
great to see all these scientists coming
together
to bring their skills together in an
integrative way to try to come up with
solutions
for
beginning uh well at the beginning of
the pandemic there was this great panic
thinking oh god what's going to happen
to
to science and interaction and
collaboration seeing as people were not
going to be meeting in person
so as i mentioned before we have a
really outstanding media team
which was really quickly able to pivot
uh everything that i showed you before
started coming out in late march
and uh pretty early on we had our first
international uh joint symposium the
qcrg covet 19 research symposium which
was a great success we had
over 800 people in attendance
and we had speakers from all over the
world from nigeria from argentina from
the united states from france just to
name a few of the places that the
speakers came from
all of them and their current research
on covet 19
and leading to further talks among those
scientists similarly we recently had
another joint symposium with the
weitzman institute in israel focusing on
molecular systems biology
and this is precisely to to foster
collaborations between
these two groups so whereas we have a
history with some other
groups this was the first symposium with
uh with these scientists
and we were concerned about the ability
to
have discussion because as you know when
you're in person you're able to go have
coffee or whatnot
and so the media team was very creative
in creating different breakout rooms uh
for people to meet and discuss
actual projects which are now about to
begin between these two groups
i'll be at the distance coming up soon
we have our second annual
uh symposium with the institut pasteur
which will focus on infectious diseases
this will be in
october as well as a symposium with
you university college dublin in ireland
uh sbi a symposium on molecular networks
of cancer and other diseases
and so we're looking forward to all of
these and this is just to say that
really
the collaborative spirit does not have
to stop just because we can't be in
person
and these are going on and still
creating these great opportunities for
scientists to come
together and back to nevin
segway for the last point that we uh
want to make
uh and i hope you agree with us that the
theme really has been about
collaborations and
and really breaking down barriers and
silos to bring scientists together and
i have to say i do have problems with
the scientific enterprise
and how science is framed and in that it
often rewards the individual
and it often as well penalizes those
that
ultimately want to collaborate but what
we've seen here in this awful pandemic
is
we can move incredibly quick quickly if
we want to
if we work together if we can break down
these silos across different
laboratories like i've shown you with
qcrg across different institutions like
we've done
around the world and then building
relationships between the academic world
and the pharmaceutical industry as well
and the question i have is why aren't we
doing science like this all the time you
know why did we need a pandemic
in order to conduct science in this
manner and i think as scientists the
challenge will be
once the dust settles can we keep this
spirit alive
and can we tackle other diseases
breast cancer alzheimer's parkinson's
why aren't we working on all diseases
like this
and i think if we work like this we'll
be much uh
more ready for the next pandemic be it
you know covet 22 cover 24 or whatever
other virus that comes our way
ultimately in the future so um
we gave credit to a lot of our
collaborators i just want to show you
lastly a picture of our lab
and just to highlight a few people in
the bottom left-hand corner is dave
gordon
who worked closely with gwendolyn jang
who's in the top right hand corner
to generate the first sars kovi ii
protein protein interaction map that
we talked about medi who's in the back
who's the tall
individual in the back row he led the
work uh
on our phosphorylation global
phosphorylation analysis and infected
cells
and then three other individuals i'll
just say their names here danielle
swaney ruth
the fantastic group leading our mass
spec
efforts so it's been great to work with
them and all of these people and all
these
collaborators and we thank you for your
attention and we'll be happy to take
questions now
thank you and jacqueline for your time
and for your important research
informative presentation i'm going to
start live
in a portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you want to ask please do
now click on the question box located
let's get started we have a few
questions that have already come in
excited we need a better understanding
of what is a host as itself a natural
host
can you help us with that i'm sorry
susie you're breaking up a little bit
there is
can can you repeat that question i said
the question that they have is we need a
better understanding
of what it posed as its
host which
which can you tell me what number that
question is i'm sorry i like
number two i just put it in our
presenter chat nevin
okay
you need a better i mean what is a host
as itself and natural host
um i i think that's in line with
you know the vision of what we talked
about today and
a lot of time people just want to focus
on the pathogen
but the pathogen needs our genes and our
proteins in order to in
us so a better understanding of the host
i think would reveal secrets that we
could ultimately exploit
in um coming up with novel uh therapies
and
you know along those same lines um what
we're starting to do now is to study
um this virus in other hosts as we all
know it
ultimately came from a bat sarge kobe 2
as did stars kobe 1
the work of the dolpho garcia sastra
to generate um bat uh sars cov1 and
stars coffee two protein protein
interaction maps and
trying to use those maps to help inform
you know why white and these live a
reservoir in these bats and why are they
so problematic
in us so i think studying these viruses
across
the different hosts will be very
informative in terms of coming up
hopefully with
with new strategies going forward
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in
vitro missing antibodies disqualified
for coverage
uh which number was that susie
and we've gone ahead and put it in the
chat for you to help right there
um yeah i mean it's there's there's a
lot of work on going
um with respect to anybody's i briefly
alluded to
a couple of efforts that came out of the
qcrg one led by ashish
manglik and peter walter where they have
nanobodies
that they've developed that are very
very potent in the in vitro setting and
now the challenge is to see
you know can you get these antibodies
and individuals
uh to to you know potentially have any
therapeutically there's a number of
groups
that have ident identified very powerful
not even an individual setting and it
remains to be seen that it could be
translated into having an effect
in in us to have any antiviral effects
but it's i think it's a fantastic
strategy a biological
strategy to inhibit the virus and you
know we talked a lot about coming up
with drugs and compounds
to inhibit the virus you can come up
with biological strategies using
antibodies and there's a lot of work
i'm going a lot of the work qcrg has
been dedicated to that as well
so taking multiple lines here to try to
combat this virus is going to be crucial
and maybe it'll be a combination of a
biologic with a drug or a compound
that could be the cocktail we'll have to
just wait and see but i'm happy a lot of
people
a lot of smart people are working on
this problem so it gives me hope that
i'm not with you with one of these
thank you so much what are the major
differences
between sorry you in 2003.
[Music]
could you put that question in the chat
please it's in the chat
yep
i assume you're saying what is the
difference between stars one in 2003 and
then
that covet um 19. um you know we're
one major difference here is that
obviously stars one was at a much higher
mortality rate
uh but it was um it didn't spread as
easily
and in that way compared to stars kobe 2
and then that way i think it was easier
to get under control the problem with
starscopy 2 is it spread so easily
mortality rate's lower but it spreads so
easily and there's so many people that
are asymptomatic that's why it's so hard
to get under control
i think compared to star score v1 so
we're studying it at a molecular level
so i briefly showed our sars cobie one
map
the projector actual map and compared it
to cyrus kobe two it's very similar
um and but there are differences and
we're trying to use our suite of
integrated tools
to look at those differences they're
both experimental and computational
tools
to try to get a better insight of
you know why do these viruses behave
differently why was sargo v1
have higher mortality less infectious
compared to sars kobe 2. we have some
interesting threads
that we've identified and now the
challenge is to test them
in cells in animal models and then
ultimately
test our predictions at a clinical
setting as well so um
we're working on it using the tools we
have and we have some interesting leads
and i think at a molecular level we'll
have
some very interesting things to report
in the very near future thank you so
much
our next question is is there any
neurological
impact of sars kovi ii
as in mers virus
well i'm not obviously i'm not a
clinician here but
i think a lot of people know that
there's been a lot of neurological
um problems being reported um
and these could be long-term the virus
hasn't been along around long enough for
us to know how long-term these
neurological
issues could uh could be so
um the answer is yes and it's not just
neurological but there's heart issues
there's
it seems like this virus gets into a lot
of different organs and causes a lot of
different problems and this is another
reason why it's so hard to get it under
control so
i think we're just scratching the
surface in terms of understanding the
neurological uh impact um
that we'll have uh with respect to sars
kobe 2.
in that regard at least from our angle
what we've been doing is starting to
generate these maps
in different cell types and
cardiomyocytes we're starting to do this
in neurons now so it'll be very
interesting at a molecular level to see
the differences and maybe we can you
know say something
intelligent about the protein or the
gene level of
why we're seeing all these organs being
impinged upon and hopefully we can start
to make some
important hypotheses about differences
that we see when we go from organ to
organ
thank you so much and evan does the
affinity to the ace2 receptor
have to do with the difference between
infecticity or
of the two stars for example viruses
i think yeah that's a good question um i
think there's going to be a number of
uh different reasons of why um we see
different
um you know rates of infection between
stars kobe 1 and
we too that definitely could run um but
i think what we need is a more
systematic study of
not just looking at you know ace ii and
spike but looking at the entire
repertoire
of connections between all the human
proteins and all the viral proteins in
order to make
uh kind of a more global unbiased
assessment of
of why we see these differences between
these different tires
and so we're on the trail as are many
other groups and we're collaborating
with a lot of groups as well
to kind of suss all that out
thank you so much in view of the
sequence
homology do neutralizing antibodies
towards sars cove one and or mers
have neutralizing activity against stars
co v2
i mean that's a great question i don't
think i know the answer i don't think we
know the answer to that
um as of um yet um
i mean the the if you can focus i mean
the whole logic here one of the logics
that i presented early on
is if you can focus on biology it's
served across
ours once ours tumors and other
carnoviruses
if you can focus on the commonalities in
terms of coming up
with the strategy i'd be it either
chemical or
biologic the idea is that it would be
hopefully applicable for
sars 3 as well so all the information
that's being generated across the board
across all these
corner of ours looking for these
commonalities the goal is hopefully we
would come up with a strategy that would
be pan corn virus
and would be better prepared for the
next pandemic and the next corn virus
pandemic
because we all know what's coming
thank you very much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
this next question is a two-part
question how long will studies take to
determine whether prior
infection confers immunity and for how
long
and the second part of that is there are
numerous individuals
who believe they had stars cov2 in late
fall
early winter 2019 isn't it possible
that there was a different strain or
mutation at that time
um so this is talking about immune
response
um and you know this as a caveat this is
not my area of expertise but i can tell
you my opinion on this
um so my feeling is the jury's still out
in terms of how much immunity one gets
when they've been infected with
cyroscopy there's been a cup there's
been two cases reported that people have
been
in infected again um but i just think
more data is required in order to make
those um type of
statements um in terms of the second
part the mutations
you know i don't think this virus is
mutated quick enough there's been like
one mutation reported and
i guess the spike protein that there's a
paper from a cell from the scripps
institute saying that
um this mutation made it more infectious
but not more problematic not with a
higher mortality rate
um but i i just i don't think this virus
is mutated enough
for it to be uh to have concerns the
question would be will this be like
influenza well
every year you're going to have to deal
with another virus that's that's
that's been different i mean one of the
things that you can say between flu and
coronavirus is that the proofreading
enzymes associated with quarter virus
are five times more efficient than the
proofreading enzymes
that are associated with influenza and
that's that would say that it mutates a
lot less
than influenza so uh the hope would be
is we come up with a strategy for
cova 19 that it would be applicable for
other corner viruses in the future
in a much more effective way than what
we have for these flu vaccines that
have varying responses year to year and
that's because
the flu virus is mutated much more quick
quickly than
stars cytoscopy too thank you very much
will levels of expression of ace two
determine the
um tire of the infection or is there a
cross talk
and the other pathway becomes more
active when ace 2 is low
it's a great question you know obviously
i think ace 2 is a key
protein here in the host that the virus
manipulates to infect our cells but
i think a lot of people are focused on
these two as they should but i think
uh a more you know the approach we're
taking is a more of an unbiased approach
to see
what other proteins there are it's not
just going to be through one protein
there's going to be a mirror out of
proteins
and there's going to be a crosstalk as
the question alludes to between these
different proteins so a more
comprehensive understanding of
all the proteins and how they talk to
one another
the host proteins in our cells is going
to be very illuminating
to to get at really the mechanisms of
infection and once
we have a better understanding isms then
hopefully that'll lead to a better
therapy
in the future nevin given the relatively
low mutation rate do you think that sars
kobe 2
is relatively stable virus genome
hence making a vaccine to homo
logos region relatively effective
that's the that's the hope right that's
the logic uh i hope that's true
that any strategy that we come up with
for kova 19 will be applicable to covet
22 or covert 24.
um but it remains to be seen we need
more data to see if that's actually
going to come to fruition or not but i'm
hopeful and many other people
are hopeful because it seemingly does
mutate as fast as other
sets of viruses that a strategy that we
come up with
could be beneficial for a long time
now does the qbi have a common notorious
study who
uh with drugs including antiviral
currently
in process and what is the general time
frame
if you do for those studies
well we're talking in a couple of
different ways these combinatorial
studies um
a lot of work we've done in the past the
qbi have been genetic interaction so
so um genetic pairwise genetic
perturbation studies
um and and getting that pathway
information that way well you can
perturb a gene with a
with a with a crisper or you can perturb
it with a compound
so what we've been doing now is
combinatory studies perturbing genes
with rnai or crispr and then combining
them with drugs to get a
better understanding of you know what
what ultimately what drug combinations
would work but we're also doing
uh double and triple drug components as
well but there's
you know it's it scales exponentially
here when you start to look at all these
and you want to be intelligent in terms
of which combinations you pick
that's why i think it's so important to
lay down this foundation of information
that we're trying to do
to get a better you know look or uh
generate these maps of
of how the virus infect these maps to be
intelligent in terms of picking
which combinations or or triplets of
drugs
could uh ultimately uh be effective and
i think that's where
the strategies that we've talked about
today are going to be particularly
pertinent
is when we start to go to these
different combinations and
you need to know if these different
genes these different targets are
working in the same pathway in a
different pathway
in order to be intelligent in terms of
which combination so that's the
direction we're headed and
we're uh we have expertise in the past
to do this and we're excited to be using
our tools in this way in the future
and evan our next audience member wants
to know does the vitro enhancement
function
of antibodies correlate with in vitro
disease enhancements
i think we had susie i think we talked
about that one before
that was the one that was uh asked at
the beginning um
okay perfect and how about um the coven
19
infection how long will the kuvin19
infection continue
as per your expectation
well i hope it's i hope it goes away
tomorrow uh but
i mean it's i don't know it's a great
question it's it's a it's a
question no one really knows the answer
to so i mean the hope would be that
there would be some effective treatments
here by the end of the year or a vaccine
at the beginning of next year or
patiently early in 2021. um
there's a lot of people as i said
working on this never has there been a
problem that so many people have worked
on uh
many of them together so i'm hopeful
that there's going to be some
breakthroughs on a number of fronts
by the end of the year that'll give us a
number of different operations that
hopefully could be implemented in 2021
and the goal would be
a year from now hopefully we're in a
much much better position so i'm hopeful
that
will be the case thank you
now we have time for a few more
questions are you concerned about
immune invasion and producing more
violent
viruses
uh i guess that's related to um
you know viruses mutating and overcoming
our
defense mechanisms so yes always with a
virus this is
um the problem we got kind of a taste of
that with a
with a mutation in the spike protein
it's seemingly as i said it made it
martian but not more deadly which was
good
so that's always a huge concern is that
the viruses are a lot smarter than us
um and we have to respect them but then
try to trick them into telling us what
their secrets are at the end of the day
so
the the more we can respect them and
trick them i think uh
um hopefully we can come up with
strategies
more quickly than they can mutate and
cause troubles for almost that's the
goal and i think if we
the whole message of jacqueline and my
symposium was to about collaboration and
i think if we
see this as a an effort a collaborative
effort that we need to do to come
together to fight this virus i think we
can come up with those droughts
but see as us versus it i guess going
forward at least that's the way i see it
and
the scientific community has come
together in an unprecedented way and
we've got to
keep them coming together more and more
to fight this
really nasty virus
now why is it that given two individuals
of the same age of baseline health who
are infected with stars
cov2 one may suffer severe disease
and the other may have just like a uri
type of kind of symptom
yeah it's a fantastic question it's one
we're starting to delve into
um you know a lot of people we would
love a discussion
mutations of the virus and what effects
that has on infection well
what you're asking there is essentially
variance on the host
and i think it's fascinating to the work
that's ongoing now
you know taking these different groups
of people those that are infected with
stars copy 2 seemingly the same
age race sex
you know economic status why does one
have no symptoms and the other is on a
respirator and i think
there's a lot of effort out going on in
terms of sequencing those individuals
and and finding the genes the the
variants on those genes
that could help explain these very
important differences and that's where
our maps are so powerful once you
identify those genes in those studies
you can then overlay that information on
the maps that we're generating
and then in a real way you can start to
make predictions
you know in the lab and then going back
to the people and back and forth
so we've been doing work like this on
hiv studying
people that are essentially resistant to
hiv
and identifying the mutations or the
variants in
those cases of why they're resistant and
then study them molecularly
and uh we're going in that direction as
well in collaboration with a number of
different groups
both the united states um and and europe
but
that's why it's so important to have
this foundational set of data these
foundational maps
so you can overlay other types or these
genomic type of analyses that you that
that you just alluded to uh it's it's a
very powerful way to interpret this and
this is the direction that we're headed
and i think that's going to reveal a lot
of secrets as well with respect to the
buyers
yeah we have time for two more questions
i'm just going to shift to
talking a little bit about access and
ethics
when we actually have a vaccine how will
be assured that all individuals have
access to it for example those who
may not have insurance and how long will
it take to be available to everyone do
you think
i mean these are great questions i mean
this is where you need your
the leadership of the countries to
intervene and
and make sure those that are most at
risk would get it first
obviously that's that probably will not
happen and hopefully it happens more
than
we want it to but that comes down to
leadership
and uh hopefully we have leaders that
stand up and and do the right things and
how long will it take as i said before i
mean you listen to tony fauci you listen
to cdc
um hopefully sometime early if not mid
you know 2021 there is some sort of
vaccine
that could be useful and the challenge
then is obviously once you have it
it's scaling it up and distributing it
these are massive massive issues right
so
if you had one tomorrow it doesn't mean
people could get it you know in the next
week it would take
you know several months to distribute it
to scale it up and distribute it but
i mean as i said i mean the goal would
be hopefully like a year from now
there'd be
uh different options on the table that
could be helping all of us and hoping a
vaccine will be one of those options
and evan do you have any ethical
concerns about how quickly a vaccine is
being developed
uh i not ethical in terms of how fast
it's being developed i guess it's
ethical in terms of
getting people to to take them and and
taking risks when they take them and um
there's been a few cases in the news in
the past week along those lines
and so yes those are concerns but it's a
balance in terms of getting this virus
under control and then it's a balance in
you know individuals taking a vaccine um
that may not be completely
uh understood so it is there's certain
ethical issues that you one needs to
consider but it's on both sides of this
so
it's a huge challenge and you know the
world the scientific world is just
trying to come up with solutions that
will help everybody
thank you actually we have time for one
more question
how long after infection can antibodies
against
stars kobe 2 still be detected in
someone's blood
yeah that's a great that's a great
question more data is
quite for that um i think that
yeah i i would you know there's certain
if you look back at stars kobe 1 there's
studies where actually people that were
infected with stars kobe 1 still have
antibodies you know 17 years later
um you know that's that's one case and
there's other cases
oscilloscopy two that have been reported
or antibodies are wayne so
i think again this is the case with the
jury's still out and more more data is
going to be required
to make intelligent comments along those
lines which will obviously impact
immunity and ultimately vaccine
development but as i said there's a lot
of smart people working on this so
hopefully we'll get some answers along
those lines
some some accurate answers along those
lines very soon
absolutely jacqueline nevin thank you
both for doing this presentation today
would you like to provide any closing
remarks before we go
i would uh jacqueline did you want to
say a few things
uh well i think nevin and i will
probably echo each other in this but i
think that
what we've seen happening in the last
six months is that we've seen the
scientific community come together and
have
such incredible rapid progress towards a
very difficult question and uh it begs
the other question as to why would you
ever do science differently
and i think um we definitely echo each
other in this way if you found a way
that's better
why would you go backwards and not
continue doing it
sure yeah jacqueline said it better than
i could just just to
kind of reiterate the challenges as i
said before is to keep
this spirit keep this infrastructure in
place and i think we really need to look
at how we do science and how the
structure set up how the reward
structure is set up
and and now it's flipping around to flip
things around because you know in some
ways we have a clean slate so
let's take a few steps back and say well
how do we really want to do this
now is the time to change it so also
it's been a huge tragedy with this
pandemic but
there's several linings here we can
change things we can change things for
the good and i hope we can do that as a
scientific community
thank you both again for your time today
and for your important research
and before we go i want to thank the
audience members for joining us today
and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for six
months
up until march 2021. labradors will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
stay healthy and take care bye-bye
thank you thank you